you
[Music]
white corn is one of our relatives we
feel as she is alive she wants to do the
job that she told our Creator she would
do is to feed our people to nourish them
the work that we do if we didn't have
this way we would lose everything
[Music]
for a few thousand years Potawatomi
people have been incredible farmers and
have grown lots and lots of varieties of
crops the seed library is a place where
we take crops which are disappearing
rare and endangered Potawatomi
vegetables and we grow them out and we
restore them and put them back in the
hands of native farmers
[Music]
George Martin carries the Potawatomi
tradition of making Dom Nabu or corn
soup in our seed library we have 76
unique varieties of corn each one has
its own cultural identity its own unique
flavor after a while when we stir it
you'll see how tough it gets to stir it
our corn is a lot different than other
corns which are out there if we didn't
have the seed library these traditional
food might be gone forever
within our seed library 80% of the
varieties which we take care of our rare
or nearly extinct some of the varieties
we care for here we're the only place in
the world which has them this one's
gonna be a nice one four years ago when
we first got another signal gar white
flower corn we only had a half the
canning jar a very small amount of seed
we've grown it every year since and now
we have enough that we may have a
hundred bushels fall
that's enough that next year we can
plant six or seven acres of justice corn
that's a huge increase it is important
that we keep that's what we were sent
down here for to take care of Mother
Earth and all her creations here and
that corn realizes that we're back using
it again that we're going to use it in
the feast make the corn feel good after
being used by our people again it's done
is ready to eat between tikka you know a
meal today is Holi mercy vinegar ah
mother midnight in their unit even risk
at all you know ah look there you go
this is my sister this geodes good team
us
[Music]
silly ho stick to you
London allow me to go there and buy
steam us one pack food yeah could you
don't say holiday hamburger still must
surely host a cure
he won't thingy my dog an issue it's
about the attacks Island Discs at all so
no get them all covered I need she
looked a okay honey reunited with what I
see guidance to our games other states
could be my same Hibernia that the Kali
Yuga siento neurotic knee to 90 total
shock sumo Nikki nice e-series to our
yoga school or purchase new Casa de
she's timoni
occurred to me that this - no they say
he need another flip-flop
Juvenal young hip this month's topic oh
can I do enough is -
you know karate sighs domani total
balance day sweida serious ASIMO rip
Anatomy was heretical 9100 Kafka wanna
impact or nine decade or two dr. sakeena
can see the whole city in kanji
[Music]
co-hosted a two Koreas meet a more Q&A
series gossipy need a chance to go to
see also candy Dakota giving us or soda
can i as a cowardly touch the courtesy
to neva not dicta clean or you could
utter seducing critique and Achilles
[Music]
yeah modesta guru ah you see what a
Pocono
kudamon over a cigar smoker I might
occur what she took up okay sandy
did I come at you by mass again I - you
are a mother some skylights name
in the fertile Hills of Derbyshire
England
one man is cultivating something unique
I'm Kevin Munroe I grow furniture this
is our furniture orchard
we've got chairs this side lamps over
here tables little further on that way
and they're all manner of things in
between the original idea came from
realizing that the way that we make
furniture now we have to grow the trees
for at least 50 years and then cut them
down and we make them into smaller and
smaller and smaller bits before sticking
them back together again why bother with
that at all
why indeed Gavin trains the branches of
young trees by attaching them to
specially made forms he then grasp them
together to form one solid piece slowly
they grow into fully formed pieces of
furniture but exactly how slow are we
talking for a chair to grow that takes
five to ten years depending on the
species the thing is if you thinking
about this in the bigger picture
then by the time you've grown your tree
for 50 years we'll have at least 10
generations of tears rolled out while it
seems slow in real terms of making
things out of wood it's actually pretty
quick
when we harvest the trees we're not
killing them the varieties that we use
all grow back again the next year on the
environmental front it's not just
efficient it's uber efficient we've got
this lovely curve coming up here when we
sand this down this little triangles
gonna look gorgeous we can get them into
the workshop and the fun begins on the
production side and we can start to kind
of bring together geometry and nature
the finishing is where we can really let
that shine and no one can deny that
Gavin's furniture is beautiful but is it
functional not only do we think that
they'll be stronger they'll be way
stronger because they're one solid piece
there's no joints to come loose what
we're doing here is collaborating with
the trees it's kind of a beautiful way
of working
really
[Music]
[Music]
there's a world-renowned topiary garden
in the tiny town of Bishopville South
Carolina and that garden was created by
this man a man named pearl
[Music]
I'm pearl Fryar and this is my gardener
[Music]
pearl started the garden in 1981 with
the goal of winning yard of the month
from the local garden club I went to our
neighborhood about house and the reason
they didn't want to say I mean I have
they said yeah there was a stereotype at
the time the African Americans didn't
keep up their yards so I figure when
you're a mom and the person that made
that statement could understand you
can't get by one person
[Music]
once I got yard and my people couldn't
believe it Pro now has over 300 plants
most of which were throw aways that came
from the recycling bin at a local
nursery I don't water Islands free and
free life I use no chemicals it's all
natural it's all pretty we have done
organically some of my tallest plant
that was recycled is around 30 feet so
many people drove by Pearl's house to
see his garden that he opened it up to
the public I would say about ten
thousand people visit my god maybe
people come from all over the world to
see it I had people from Australia Japan
Korea I want to share because so many
people came out in from one receive the
very settle and see something god I was
so simple and making them mad at this
guy
the garden is about love and the last
thing you see before you leave my father
love peace
[Music]
if the spinergy found a COSM as though
it is in Cornish locust a loose camera
come on ref lahar mice trading food
Anastasios impreza yell okay no steady
comma nosotros those campesinos me if I
mean yellow si por el desfile de pollo
as a poor person is algo muy de spin be
also easy New Year's Apache oh no sorry
Hamasaki mean hombres Ariana Patricia
you run as a mother 8th annual my
familiars venomous participant oh no ok
say conquers all this village Potter and
the Philosopher's Stone a manifestation
cultural Dundas Ellison reconocimiento
cheese case lkj Valdez erogenous Navajo
[Music]
initial maintain like konami IE
transport a gassy alimony moola porque
no avian las carreteras por su estado
and consist of Thomas eldest como
nuestro departamentos de votación kappa
terre mi familia fence ahmo's que bueno
reflects our a new ng paulo que es la
cultura el café entonces vikulova
Engelen odd o con todo lo que c'est un
policía en la finca cafe Terra para
llegar a process our una Pepa de cafe
say tambien de los dias organized ando
yeah siento hermano hey lvq lo se Monta
casita pour casita americ-aa de una cosa
tan minutiae o cemente porque kako seat
acquaintance historia
el desfile de paz gaje member eos
category --is y participa Mohsen Barrios
categories esta la catégorie ah de carga
Greek Ola tambien concur Samia janessa
categoria
art ACO fishes tambien Cosimo's que es
me categoria
el concurso ng paulo la première Sione's
dinero y pano casi todos los angeles
epremier puesto para el numero uno
adriana a partisan a manifestation
cultural es algo familia de trois Takagi
para una familia y otra deca Emilia una
historia con ser los campos antes que o
Cassy siempre samba los mismos pero como
va de nuevas Hamer a Sione's de trois
nuestra tres Emma's porque es como Ella
God okay a Hamas in cada uno en nuestros
hijos corridos
[Music]
[Applause]